6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6-Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Beth
and I'm Neil. You can find a transcript and worksheet for this podcast on our website
bbclearningenglish.com. So Neil, today we're talking about animal migration.
That's the movement of animals from one place to another, usually because of the weather
or temperature. Yes, for example, will the beast are famous for their migration? They travel
around the Serengeti in Tanzania and the Masai Mara in Kenya every year depending on the rain.
It's often called the Great Migration. Yes and I have a question for you about this Neil.
How many animals are thought to take part in the Great Migration every year? Is it a 1 million,
b 1.5 million or c 2.5 million? Well, I don't know, but I'm going to guess 2.5 million.
Okay, I'll reveal the answer at the end of the programme. Now, will the beast are not the only
animals who travel large distances? That's right. Many sharks also migrate. They move to a different
place because of the weather or temperature. Trisha, at word, researches sharks and their migration
for Utah State University and explained more to BBC World Service programme, the Climate Question.
Animals migrate for all types of reasons. Some of them migrate for food resources,
things like mating or for giving birth. So, animals can migrate for food, mating and giving birth.
Host of the BBC World Services, the climate question Sophie Eastor wanted to know more.
And what kind of distances are we talking with these migrations? Are they covering huge swathes of
ocean? Some of these sharks species can travel massive distances. We've seen great white sharks that
have travelled from the coast off of Perth, Australia, all the way to South Africa. Sophie asks, what kinds of
distances are we talking with these migrations? This is an informal way to ask how far are the
migrations? We can rephrase lots of questions in this way. For example, you could ask, what kind of
price are we talking to ask how much something costs? Sophie goes on to ask whether sharks travel across
huge swathes of ocean. Swathes of ocean means large areas of ocean. Yes, and in fact, sharks do travel
across large areas. For example, great white sharks can travel from Australia to South Africa. That
is a long way to swim. But as climate change causes changes to the temperature of the ocean,
it's changing the way that sharks migrate. This is a problem. Sharks scare away other creatures,
such as sea turtles. And these creatures eat sea grass, which absorbs a lot of carbon from
the atmosphere. So basically, when the sharks are around, there's more sea grass on the ocean floor
and so more carbon is absorbed. So sharks can actually help fight climate change. Yes, in fact,
lots of species that migrate are really important for fighting climate change. Let's say more from
BBC World Service Programme, the climate question. Sharks aren't the only migratory animal that acts
as a secret weapon against climate change. Research that we worked on shows that by just managing
about 10 groups of animals, we could be taking out or sequestering morissio 2 from the atmosphere
by about six gigatons of carbon per year. So for perspective, some experts say that we need to suck
10 gigatons of CO2 a year out of the atmosphere to meet our climate goals. So if he says that many
animals that migrate, like sharks, are a secret weapon against climate change, a secret weapon
is something nobody knows about that will give you an advantage over a problem or enemy.
By protecting sharks and other animals that migrate, Tricia's research shows that we could be
sequestering six gigatons of carbon dioxide or CO2 a year from the atmosphere. So,
question means remove and store the carbon, for example, implants like sea grass. Six gigatons
is a lot of carbon. Sophie says that for perspective, it's about 60 percent of the amounts of carbon
dioxide that some scientists believe we need to remove from the atmosphere each year. We can
use the phrase for perspective to explain the size or importance of something, particularly when
it's difficult to imagine that thing. Alongside sharks, another species that Tricia believes is
important to helping remove carbon dioxide from the atmosphere is the wills beast. Yes,
and that reminds me of your question, Beth. You asked me how many animals take part in the great
migration and I think I went for option C2.5 million. Was I right? You weren't. I'm afraid.
The answer was B1.5 million, so still a lot of animals. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've
learnt starting with migrate. Move to a different place. For animals, this is usually because of the
weather or temperature. We can use the structure, what kind of something are we talking to rephrase a
question more informally, particularly one about distance, cost or numbers. For example, what kind
of distance are we talking? Swathes means large areas of something. A secret weapon is something nobody
knows about that gives you an advantage over a problem or enemy. If you sequester something, such as
carbon dioxide, you remove it and store it. And we can use the phrase for perspective to explain
the size or importance of something, particularly if that thing is difficult to imagine.
Once again, our six minutes are up. Why not test what you've learnt using the interactive quiz
on our website? Bye for now. Goodbye.